Happy new year everybody
To welcome so many of you today
to celebrate this year's Hombu Dojo Kagamibiraki,
fills me with joy.
This is made possible thanks to the support and cooperation of everybody.
I would like to thank you from the bottom
of my heart.
This is where we stand today, on the grounds of this dojo,
that in 1932, the Founder established the Ueshiba Dojo.
In 1968, the Second Doshu Kisshomaru,
turned the original [wooden] structure into the present reinforced concrete dojo.
Today it has been 50 years.
Today, Aikido has spread to, and unified people from around 130 countries.
Last year, I gave a seminar during the 50th anniversary of Argentinian Aikido.
The event was an occasion for 1000 people to get together.
During my journey, I passed the Strait of
Magellan
and visited the small island of Ushuaia.
There too, there were 50 people practicing Aikido.
Moreover,
the Hombu Dojo-cho Ueshiba Mitsuteru held a seminar in Cape Town,  at the southwestern tip of Africa,
to celebrate Republic of Africa's 40th Aikido anniversary.
Those events took place at he southwestern tips of both Africa and America.
He [Hombu Dojo-cho] also went to Iceland, which is the northernmost land.
In these places, there are people who are diligently training in Aikido.
I believe that it is the thanks to the wonderful nature of the Founder's Aikido,
and the diligent training and transmission
by many people, from then up to today,
that the creation of such a wide circle of
unity was possible.
Of course, it is my duty to maintain
this flow of transmission of Aikido in its correct form, to the next generation,
and to contribute to society by using the positive values learnt through Aikido in daily life.
This is what I think we ought to do.
If we want to achieve this, we will need to
continue training in a diligent and resolute manner.
I hope to continue, this journey with you
all, together,
so please, this year again, keep on training hard.
Thank you very much.